sabían ustedes quién hacemos dos veces
la primera vez que nacemos en nuestro
nacimiento biológico la segunda vez es
cuando tenemos alrededor de 810 años y
es el minuto en que tenemos sueños
cuando yo tenía esa edad
tuve una gran inspiradora que fue la
primera mujer que se puso un casco y se
subió un cohete era valentina tereshkova
la primera cosmonauta
valentina fue mi inspiradora porque yo
me preguntaba si ya se puso un casco
porque yo no porque no nosotras
por supuesto
que mi perra se llamaba laica y ella me
acompañó muchas veces en esta
carrera hacia la convicción hacia la
manera de cómo íbamos y como yo también
podía o mis colegas mis amigas construir
y fortalecer el sueño que uno tiene a
esa edad me detengo un rato a esa edad
es cuando nos damos cuenta que la
sociedad en la que vivimos es la que nos
gusta y a veces en la que no nos gusta
nos damos cuenta qué tipo de casa
vivimos cómo son las relaciones
familiares cómo es también la escuela
cómo es mi barrio a qué me interesa que
me interesa menos y por lo tanto
empezamos a fraguar sueños esos sueños
que se transforman con el tiempo en
posibilidades a veces quedan detenidos y
quedan detenidos por barreras por
barreras que a veces son reales
y a veces son mentales a veces son
tecnológicas a veces son
comunicacionales etcétera siempre van a
haber barreras siempre alguien nos va a
decir que no pero no es por eso que los
sueños tienen menos valor y por eso en
mi carrera y en mi vida tuve que
cultivar esta convicción por lo
siguiente
porque cuando uno tiene una idea
una intención y me quiere movilizar sus
acciones no basta con tener esa idea y
ese sueño tenemos que aprender a
trabajar lo que yo llamo un night bear y
este es el primero que les voy a
presentar es el aire personal porque
cuando uno tiene que convencer a un jefe
como tuve que hacerlo porque llegando a
chile de haber estudiado fuera no
calzaba bien mí lo que yo había
estudiado con lo que quería hacer acá
tuve que modificar y vi que chile
necesitaba espacios para la innovación
estoy hablando de hace 25 años atrás
estos espacios para la innovación no
existían por lo tanto yo tenía que
robustecer esa idea y ese sueño y esa
convicción
y por lo tanto lo primero que me parecía
importante era observar que el mundo
estaba en el que yo estaba viviendo acá
en chile y en segundo lugar tenía que
armar me mi propia disciplina personal
mi propio cuento mi propia rutina sin
ello yo no iba a poder llegar a
robustecer esta idea luego y una parte
importante y que todos coincidimos hoy
día es generar pensamiento propio
porque no basta repetir lo que dicen los
autores los libros nosotros tenemos que
tener nuestra propia interpretación de
la realidad que nos circunda eso es muy
importante para generar identidad para
generar credibilidad
y para poder lograr movilizar también a
otras personas por lo tanto
esto también nos va a servir para que
nosotros tengamos las agallas de tomar
decisiones porque esto no es fácil hay
que atreverse hay que tener un cierto
coraje y tenemos que estar arropada
tenemos que estar sólidas tenemos que
tener argumentos porque si no las ideas
no pueden ver la luz y no pueden no
podemos dar el salto dar ese salto hay
que hay que prepararse para dar el salto
un un deportista sabe perfectamente de
lo que hablo las personas que están en
teatro también y en realidad todas
incluso todas las que hemos preparado a
estas charlas nos preparamos y hicimos
nuestras propias rutinas bien para
robustecer esta convicción que podemos
tener siempre a lo largo de la vida y
que a veces nacen cuando en los primeros
años de vida y si no van tomando
distintas formas nosotros también
necesitamos maestros no lo sabemos todos
ya sabemos que no basta con estudiar y
que no basta con estudiar en la
universidad y no basta ni siquiera tener
un título
hoy día necesitamos tener una multi
disciplina tener una visión más amplia y
por lo tanto necesitamos armar nuestros
propios directorios mentales yo cada vez
que necesito un tema nuevo que siempre
van ocurriendo en mi vida pues me armó
un directorio mental y ahí hay autores
hay personas hay personas que están
vivas que están aquí y hay otras que
están más lejos pero una rutina siempre
significa un aprendizaje con un maestro
o maestra aquí está mi maestra por 15
años de chi kung y artes marciales esa
es una de las disciplinas que
adoptado y que me ha servido mucho para
otro tipo de actividades
otra otro tema también relacionado con
el mundo que nos rodea y con la búsqueda
de maestro es que los maestros no están
siempre al lado a la vuelta de la
esquina
tenemos que saber buscarlo porque vamos
a necesitar los los vamos a necesitar
para que nos orienten nos guíen nos
estructuren nos discutan y también por
cierto vamos a necesitar un grupo de
pares y estos grupos de pares también
los podemos ir armando y eso a mí me ha
resultado bien y ha permitido digamos
instalar
e instituciones organizaciones agencias
yo monté en la primera incubadora de
empresas que o en chile y hace 22 años
por lo tanto no estaba de moda la
innovación ni estaba de moda poner
instituciones dedicadas a la agencia de
emprendimiento por lo tanto
trabajar con distintos grupos adaptarlos
según las necesidades que nosotros vamos
viendo que tenemos es absolutamente
indispensable para que para esto para
practicar porque solo
a practicar también tengo otro haysbert
porque en él
ustedes lo que ven es me ven a mí no es
cierto en la parte visible pero por
dentro hay algunas otras cosas que
cultivado para fortalecer las
convicciones que me hacen pensar por qué
no puedo subirme al cohete porque no me
puedo poner el casco y partir hacia
territorios desconocidos que eso es lo
que más interesante me parece del
ejemplo de ésta como nauta o de
cualquier cosmonauta bueno desafiar la
ignorancia es un tema importante
trabajar en conocer en argumentar en
tener la documentación la data la
información y generar conocimiento para
poder mostrar para poder razonar para
poder convencer también a otros de otras
experiencias conocer el big picture el
el escenario me refiero donde quiero
apuntar donde quiero impactar donde
estoy buscando
redes conocimientos personas recursos
talentos para trabajar porque no lo
puedo olvidar para esta incubadora que
montamos hace 22 años atrás yo
entrevisté a 200 personas por el diario
bueno no quedó nadie las personas que
quedaron saben quiénes fueron y que nos
han servido mucho fueron las personas
que estaban en crisis de carrera y les
pedí a todos mis amigos que hacían
terapia que me dijeran y me mandaran
esas personas esa persona que
reinventaron su carrera son las que
sirvieron en primera instancia para
formarse como profesionales del
emprendimiento y la innovación varios de
ellos incluso trabajan hoy día en el
sector público entonces lo que quiero
decir es que para adentrarse en estas en
estos territorios de incertidumbre y que
hoy día el mundo estamos en territorios
de arenas a veces un poco movediza es
sumamente importante la flexibilidad
a generar habilidades cognitivas que no
son las tradicionales
esto hay que cultivarlo y creo que los
instó hoy día hay muchas maneras de
hacerlo hace 25 años no estaban todas
las tecnologías disponibles y hoy día si
las tenemos bueno los espacios de
aprendizaje también esas esos tenemos
que también junto con estas comunidades
de práctica ayudarnos son nuestra ayuda
son nuestro empujón para poder lanzarlo
y por supuesto también está el tema de
mantener redes activas
sobre las redes
cuántos de ustedes tienen una amplia red
de linkedin puedes levantar la mano por
favor
ok gracias bueno esta red de linkedin o
cualquier otra red que tengamos es yo
considero que es activa si y sólo si las
personas que están allí te devuelven el
llamado o el mail o el whatsapp cuando
lo necesitas para una licitación para un
proyecto para una ayuda precisa y lo
hacen pronto
lo demás es una base de datos por lo
tanto pienso que es muy importante
cultivar las relaciones regar la
plantita como dicen unos amigos no nos
basta con tener en un listado de
personas que nadie te contesta eso no
sirve para lo que queremos ahora que es
difícil necesitamos que las redes se
mantengan y nunca nunca y soy una amante
de la tecnología pero nunca la
tecnología va a reemplazar la relación
entre los seres humanos
bien para todas estas transformaciones
para lograr nuestros sueños para
subirnos al cohete necesitamos tener una
visión estratégica porque la
transformación que queremos hacer son no
son simples la innovación era un desafío
hace 20 años en las instancias
gubernamentales me miraban raros yo
venía con una gente de fuera de chile
peor todavía
nos miraban no esto aquí no cabe esto no
se puede esto es muy difícil no es la
tendencia etcétera bueno que voy a decir
hoy día está de moda y creo que el
camino ya está hecho sin embargo ahora
van a venir nuevos desafíos que hay que
saber mirar también
por lo tanto también tengo el tercer y
último ice ver
primero que nada como ya vimos declarar
la visión una visión de largo plazo por
lo menos de mediano plazo porque si nos
quedamos aquí no de aquí no vamos a
sacar nada de aquí para el mundo porque
está en la complejidad el mundo del día
es incierto es mucho más complejo
tenemos ciudadanos muy empoderados
tenemos tecnologías que nos ayudan
enormemente a la difusión de ideas
felizmente pero también tenemos que
saber seleccionarlas como vimos en el
live ver 1 y 2 pero también tenemos que
tener respaldos gente que nos apoya
otros que hablan de nosotros para poder
influenciar porque para los cambios que
queremos hacer
necesitamos un pueblo no es un grupito
pequeño de personas que solo piensan
pensar actuar practicar etcétera
relacionarse de otra manera es
tremendamente importante
bien y lo último pero no menos
importante es movilizar movilizar
activos movilizar talento movilizar
personas movilizar recursos necesitamos
movilizar y eso es lo que está haciendo
todas estas tipo de actividades que
tenemos porque porque para transformar
es difícil y sin embargo tenemos que
estar siempre dispuestas a hacerlo y
para eso tenemos que estar convencidas y
convencidos para poder realizar
quiero
finalmente
sintetizar en cuatro puntos
para que nos quedemos y nos llevemos
para la casa algunas preguntas pero
sobre todo repasar que sin convicción un
convencimiento interno es imposible que
hagamos grandes avances que necesitamos
tener el coraje necesitamos tener
conocimientos prácticas y trabajarlas
muchísimo no basta con hacerlo una vez
porque si no nos llegamos a esa
materialización
y finalmente les pregunto cuando cuando
empiezan a ustedes hacer realidad esos
sueños que tienen guardado gracias
[Aplausos]